esta vez tenemos a 7 x igual a x elevado
a la cuarta potencia menos equis elevado
a la quinta potencia y lo que vamos a
encontrar es para que valores de x en
esta función gente tiene máximos
relativos pero vamos a encontrarlos sin
graficar ayer así que qué te parece si
primero recordamos que pasan en un
máximo relativo y para eso vamos a
dibujar por aquí una función hipotética
se mejor de dibujar algo así ok y ahora
lo que quiero que veas es qué es lo que
pasa en un máximo relativo si observas
por aquí tenemos un máximo relativo por
aquí también y por aquí también y que
tienen en común estos tres puntos bueno
que la función va decreciendo a
decreciendo en cada uno de esos puntos
verde creciendo a decreciendo
decreciendo a decreciendo en cada
uno de estos máximos relativos o también
podemos decir que la primera derivada de
esta función antes de llegar al máximo
va a ser positiva la primera derivada va
a ser positiva y pasando este punto
máximo
la primera derivada va a ser negativa es
decir que la derivada va a cambiar de
ser positiva a ser negativa positiva
cuando crece y negativa cuando decrece
entonces lo que realmente quiero es
pensar en cuando la primera derivada de
esta función cambia de signo cambia de
positiva a negativa así que vamos a
escribir lo voy a encontrar un máximo
relativo un máximo relativo
cuando uno pasa lo siguiente cuando se
priman cambian de positiva a negativa
cambian de positiva a negativa
entonces vamos a buscar cuando cambian
que priman de positiva a negativa es
decir que prima de x en este caso es
mayor que 0 y va a cambiar a que prima
de x menor que es cero y bueno para esto
que te parece si primero buscamos los
puntos críticos recuerdan un punto
crítico es cuando prima de x esto es
igual a cero o que prima de x sea
indefinido entonces vamos a pensarlo
primero vamos a buscar los puntos
críticos y después vamos a fijarnos en
donde se prima cambian de positiva a
negativa y bueno donde se prima de x es
igual a cero bueno que prima de x es
igual a 0 cuando la derivada de esta
función es igual a 0 y para eso podemos
recordar la regla de la potencia la
derivada de esto
4x elevado a la 41 que es 3 - y aquí
también puede aplicar la regla de
potencia 5x elevado a la potencia 4
quiero que esto sea igual a 0 y bueno
esto va a ser igual a cero se me ocurre
que podemos factorizar una x cúbica x
kubica que multiplican a 4 menos 5 x ok
y esto ya va a ser más fácil de
igualarlo a 0 porque eso quiere decir
que x kubica es igual a cero esto en el
primer caso o 4 menos 5 x esto es igual
a cero recuerda el producto de dos cosas
es igual a cero si la primera cero
y la segunda es cero y bueno en el
primer caso me quedan en este primer
caso me queda que x es igual a cero
es en el primer caso o en el segundo
caso voy a obtener que déjame ponerlo
con este color que 4 es igual a 5 x 5 x
si sumamos 5x de ambos lados o déjame
bajar la pantalla
puedo decir que x es igual a cuatro
quintos x es igual a cuatro quintos muy
bien justo aquí es donde tengo mis dos
puntos críticos mis dos valores críticos
estos dos son los valores de x que hacen
esta derivada igual a cero ahora que te
parecen si buscamos los lugares donde
que prima de x es indefinida recuerdo un
punto crítico pasan sin que prima de x
es igual a 0
hoy sigue prima de x es indefinida
bueno nuestra función derivada está que
tengo aquí es simplemente un polinomio
observa exactamente igual que nuestra
función original por lo tanto está
definida para todos los números reales
eso quiere decir que no hay ningún valor
que haga que esto sea indefinido o dicho
de otra manera eso quiere decir que
estos dos son mis únicos valores
críticos muy bien así que si me tomo
estos dos ahora vamos a pensar qué es lo
que pasa con la función prima al lado de
estos dos valores críticos que signo va
a tomar esta función que prima de x así
que qué te parece si para verlo mejor
por aquí dibujamos una recta numérica
por aquí voy a dibujar una recta
numérica para que veamos qué pasa en los
siguientes intervalos y bueno uno de mis
puntos críticos es cero y el otros
cuatro quintos así que sería muy bien si
por aquí me pongo al menos uno por aquí
voy a poner al cero y por aquí voy a
poner
muy bien ahora uno de mis puntos
críticos es x igual a cero así que lo
voy a poner justo aquí con este color y
el otro de mis puntos críticos con color
rojo es cuatro quintos que va a estar
más o menos por aquí de lujo ahora vamos
a ver qué pasa con el primer cerca de
estos dos puntos críticos porque el
único lugar en donde podríamos cambiar
del siglo es justo aquí en estos puntos
críticos así que qué te parece si
primero pensamos que es lo que pasa en
este intervalo de aquí en este intervalo
de aquí que va a ser bueno desde menos
infinito déjame ponerlo desde menos
infinito hasta el cero